ce soir une incursion dans le monde des
trafiquants de cocaïne en 2014
le corps démembré du jeune frédéric
lavoie originaire de québec est retrouvé
en colombie c'est la mafia qui est
derrière ça marche c'est un monde
séduisant avec son style de vie
extravagant et ses promesses de fortune
mais c'est aussi un univers impitoyable
c'est sûr qu'ils cherchaient tous les
moyens pour faire le plus d'argent
possible
je pense qu'il aimait le standing que ça
pourrait lui apporter le sentiment de
pouvoir
notre journaliste martin movia s'est
rendu en colombie pour tenter d'élucider
le mystère des derniers jours de
frédéric la voix la voix voulez jouer
dans la cour des grands mais avait-il
tout ce qu'il faut pour frayer dans ce
milieu c'est ce que nous allons tenter
de découvrir
bienvenue à enquête
[Musique]
je
alors bonjour mesdames et messieurs
bienvenue à cette conférence de presse
en novembre 2012 la police frappe et
démantèle un réseau de trafiquants de
drogue
l'opération s'appelle loquace nous
pouvons donc affirmer avoir réussi à
neutraliser ce réseau en portant des
accusations non seulement contre les
distributeurs mais également contre les
tailles dirigeante de ce réseau
six hommes sont décrit par la police
comme les têtes du réseau
parmi eux il y en a un qui détonne
frédéric lavoie
un jeune homme de québec dont on n'a
jamais entendu parler des documents de
cour nous aident à vous raconter son
histoire de son ascension fulgurante
jusqu'à sa mort terrible loin des 6 ces
traces nous ont amenés en colombie
[Musique]
encore aujourd'hui la colombie est le
principal producteur de cocaïne du monde
il ce pays est intimement lié à notre
histoire par ici c'est la seule
possibilité de travail qu'on a récolté
des feuilles de coca pour faire vivre
notre famille romaine
selon les nations unies la colombie le
pérou et la bolivie produisent plus de
11 100 tonnes de cocaïne par annie à la
frontière le kilo transformer se vendra
jusqu'à 4 millions de pesos si vous avez
obtenu conviés pour la peau dure à peine
plus d'un million c'est le prix après la
transformation des feuilles de coca en
cocaïne
ce commerce devient souvent le moteur de
l'économie des régions pauvres
une fois arrivés au canada le kilo vendu
dans la rue peut laisser jusqu'à 80
mille dollars de profits ces bénéfices
font rêver ceux qui voudraient devenir
riche facilement les organisations
criminelles en profite pour recruter de
nouveaux membres
[Musique]
frédéric lavoie est né dans la région de
québec il y a grandi entouré de ses amis
et de sa famille il travaille comme
barman sur la grande allée
cette personne a été proche de frédéric
lavoie
c'est l'ambition que leurs amis là bas
c'est sûr c'est l'ambition avec les
résultats on peut voir que ça en valait
pas la peine
la voix n'avait pas le profil d'un
criminel une personne sans dossier
criminel peut devenir une personne très
important dans le rouage d'organisations
criminelles
philippe palat fait des enquêtes dans le
monde des stupéfiants durant vingt ans
il connaît bien la mentalité des
trafiquants qui s'associe à des gens au
dossier sans tache
ces personnes là semble aussi judiciaire
peuvent fréquenter et traverser les
douanes canadiennes américaines ou
autres sans laisser de traces passé sous
le radar officiellement frédéric lavoie
est un entrepreneur qui tire ses revenus
de l'industrie du tatouage
en 2009 ils achètent un appartement dans
un édifice devenu célèbre le mille de la
commune
c'est un bel immeuble mais avec beaucoup
de logements ubik sont parfois le louer
à des gens du crime organisé
pourquoi cette adresse là et ciblées par
ces gens là parce que c'est un endroit
pour fortifier un endroit sécurisé afin
de pouvoir transiger leurs activités à
l'abri de tous surtout de la police
l'ascension de frédéric lavoie aurait
été favorisée par les circonstances
selon la police c'était le bon moment
pour s'accaparer le marché de la drogue
il ya eu de nombreuses opérations
policières au cours des dernières années
qu'on parle d'eux le colisée qui était
fait par la gendarmerie royale du canada
deux axes qui était faite par le spvm ou
de shark par les espoirs régionale mixte
salle a laissé une certaine place à des
organisations criminelles
une de ces associations va mener la voie
jusqu'en colombie
[Musique]
nous sommes allés consulter un champion
de la lutte anti drogue de colombie
le général oscar naranjo le général nous
a donné cette entrevue quelques jours
seulement avant de devenir vice
président de la colombie ou juin alors
qu'adp à la casse avait dix à vingt ans
un citoyen canadien n'aurait jamais
pensé venir acheter de la drogue
directement à la source et nidal punto
de l'audi aujourd'hui il peut penser que
c'est possible et ça l'est à pratiquer
pour exposer et le passe à l'oscar
qu'elle est ce qu'il ya une chorale dans
le brasser les cartes elles voulaient
contrôler toutes les étapes du
narcotrafic et personne ne venait jouer
sur leur terrain
aujourd'hui ces organisations sont
globales et elles veulent minimiser les
risques possibles ici pour réduire les
risques
quelqu'un du canada doit venir en
colombie pour transporter la drogue les
cartes elles vont le permettre pour
faire parvenir la drogue à destination
les organisations collaborent plus que
jamais la cocaïne franchi de grandes
distances avant d'arriver aux
consommateurs on la transporte parfois à
travers la cordillère parfois sur les
fleuves
finalement la drogue arrive au port de
la côte pour être embarqués vers une
destination plus au nord ont fait que ce
que toutes leurs postes par l'amérique
centrale ou par le mexique
un arc ou trafiquant colombien a accepté
de nous parler de son commerce
à condition de cacher son identité
on envoie la drogue au mexique ils sont
responsables de la faire rentrer clio
canada si on parle des moyens de
transport on peut dire qu'on les utilise
tous
sur les avions dernièrement on a employé
de la marchandise en utilisant des
troncs de bois et ça a bien marché en
les envoyant par bateau on est assez
ingénieux on a même inventé des sous
marins des semi submersible comme celui
ci peuvent transporter jusqu'à 2 tonnes
de cocaïne côté pacifique la drogue peut
transiter par le canal de panama ou
voyager directement vers la côte est de
l'amérique du nord en passant par
l'amérique du sud où les antilles une
fois aux états unis ce sont les cartels
mexicains qui se charge de transporter
la drogue dans l'est du pays
c'est le célèbre cartel de sinaloa qui
s'en charge mais tous ces efforts ne
servent à rien si la drogue ne se rend
pas à bompas elle doit rentrer au canada
une porte d'hadrien est une personne qui
va faciliter l'entrée de la drogue par
exemple un douanier qui va faciliter
l'entrée par un port d'entrée que ce
soit par camion ou par contre les
organisations qui n'ont pas accès à ces
portes l'oeuvre ont tenté d'importer de
la drogue de toutes les façons
imaginaire possible que se soit caché
dans des plateaux de service dans les
avions
que se soit caché dans des annales ans
dans les conteneurs dans les palettes de
bois pour transporter la marchandise ou
autre mais à chaque fois qu'il ya un
risque le risque de faire saisir la
drogue
des associés de frédéric lavoie ont mis
au point un ingénieux moyen de transport
une entreprise et un propriétaire au
dossier sans tache servent de couverture
à l'importation de la drogue des camions
vont chercher des roulottes neuves aux
états unis en toute légalité
lors de procédures judiciaires et sans
qu un ancien chauffeur raconte comment
il a été recruté il me demandait si
j'avais mon passeport mon permis de
conduire
j'avais pas de casier judiciaire il m'a
dit tu voi aux états unis tu va amener
du pote puis tu vois ramener de l'argent
il m'a dit que je ferais 3500 dollars
par voyage que jean frère à toutes les
semaines même des fois peut-être deux
la drogue est chargé dans un double fond
on passait à sarnia ou windsor
parce que c'est les deux grosses douanes
dans ce coin-là fallait penser à 7h et
7h30 le soir parce qu'on nous avait dit
qu'il y avait plus d'achalandage donc y
passer moins de temps sur chaque
personne on disait aux douaniers ont sa
recherche
si on n'avait pas les roulottes
on a les pauses états unis c'était la
couverture idéale une fois la frontière
franchie
les instructions sont envoyés par
messagerie crypté sur blackberry
ces locaux recevaient notre destination
bon lot soit an à la new york portel
personnes communiquent avec lui at-elle
numéro car au lieu d'aller chercher la
roulotte
le chauffeur bifurque vers son lieu de
livraison il livre le cannabis à l'un
des différents clients américains et
ramènent un sac d'argent
après le chauffeur récupère la roulotte
et revient vers l'ontario puis le québec
beau temps mauvais temps on file vers
l'entrepôt où l'argent est livré à
l'organisation le chauffeur raconte que
son patron est généreux une soirée dans
un bar ont dépensé 15 20 milles
ils paient tout le temps content il payé
la traite à tout le monde
le transport de vielles plus stressant
lors d'une livraison à chicago le
chauffeur fait face à des clients
mexique est plutôt nerveux et ramène une
cargaison inattendue on est allé dans un
entrepôt lot il y avait des hommes armés
avec des semi automatique
c'est là que j'ai vu qu'il se passait
quelque chose de différent parce que
j'avais jamais vu d'armes avant soit
dans aucun de mes transports pour la
première fois au lieu de sacs d'argent
le chauffeur rapportent des boîtes
remplies de cocaïne de retour au québec
le chauffeur se fait sermonner je me
suis fait dire que je pourrai pu
retourner à chicago parce que j'avais
conduit croche que je les avais mis sur
les nerfs dit que je n'avais pas avec
qui choisit affaire que c'était des
cartels mexicains des gens vraiment
dangereux parce que ils voulaient me
retrouverai le témoin raconte qu'il est
allé travailler pour frédéric lavoie qui
selon lui s'approvisionner en cocaïne
grâce au stratagème des roulottes lui
c'est un fournisseur de cocaïne pour
montréal et les environs
je m'occupais d'aller voir si clients
d'apporter les kilos qui avait besoin de
récupérer l'argent de la comté j'allais
à tahoua sur la rive nord sur la rive
sud
partout il me disait d'aller qui logent
des pays au kilo que je transportais 250
dollars par kilo il y avait toute son
organisation à lui frédéric lavoie y
avait celle warner ces chauffeurs ses
associés ça roulait vraiment ces
affaires les parkings de centres
commerciaux sont témoins de rendez-vous
mystérieux où s'échangent la drogue et
l'argent parfois des centaines de
milliers de dollars
les proches de frédéric lavoie remarque
son train de vie c'est sûr que oui il y
avait un train de vie qui justifiait pas
comment moi je le connais c'est wendy
qui avaient beaucoup d'entreprises puis
aussi qui prêtaient de l'argent comme un
chat glock avec de l'intérêt élevé ce
qui était assez plausible la police
commence à s'intéresser à lui
les filatures les côtes électronique et
le travail d'agents d'infiltration
permettent d'en apprendre davantage sur
ses activités la police prépare une
opération majeure contre l'organisation
mais certains membres ont été prévenus
il va y avoir une descente ce soir ou
dans les prochains jours je me suis
arrêté le lendemain le matin de
l'opération le 1er novembre 2012
frédéric lavoie n'est pas shilvi comme
plusieurs autres accusés le public
apprendra plus tard que c'est le
policier benoît roberge qui a vendu
cette information aux motards frédéric
lavoie part en cavale comique qui
doit-il craindre le plus la police
ses présumés complices ou bien d'autres
criminels
la suite de notre enquête dans un
instant
[Musique]
medellin c'est une ville colombienne
très connu dans le monde
elie synonyme de richesse d'innovation
et d'avenir
on oublie presque qu'elle a été l'une
des villes les plus violentes au monde
la capitale mondiale du narcotrafic et
le siège social du redoutable cartel de
medellin le nom de pablo escobar est
aujourd'hui une marque de commerce qui
attire les gens je dirais que la moitié
des gens aiment pablo surtout dans les
quartiers pauvres
pour eux c'est un héros mauricio est le
guide d'un tour de plus en plus convoité
par les étrangers deux américains qui
n'ont pas voulu être identifié nous ont
permis de faire la visite avec eux le
cartel de cali voulait tuer la famille
d'escobar ici même la famille de pablo
escobar a bien failli périr dans un
attentat même de ses anciens
collaborateurs
heim et gagne sa vie en racontant les
exploits de son patron on a enregistré
jusqu'à la tour sinon c'est lui qui a
commencé les tours guidés avance à sept
et abu dhabi cause des tabous et de cd
mais celui que l'on présente aujourd'hui
comme un mythe était dans les années 80
et 90 le plus grand exportateur de
drogue au monde
après avoir tenté sa chance comme
politicien il s'est lancé dans une
véritable guerre contre les autorités
bond kidnapping il s'en est pris aux
policiers aux magistrats aux politiciens
il a fait des milliers de morts il est
devenu l'ennemi public numéro un
on est près de l'endroit où il a été tué
la police a tiré sur ses gardes du corps
et escobar a couru sur le toit
[Musique]
pablo escobar est ici omniprésent sa
tombe est toujours fleurie on a même
nommé un quartier en son honneur dans
les bidonvilles où il a construit des
maisons pour les pauvres
la ville a essayé de changer le nom du
quartier
il ne voulait pas qu'on parle de pablo
escobar la légende jesco bas et plus
vivante que jamais à medellin
là où le narcotrafic n'a jamais cessé d
ici c'est l'endroit où escobar a grandi
au nord de medellin se trouve la petite
municipalité dennevy gado ces deux lacs
pablo escobar gérait ses affaires avec
l'aide de son escadron de la mort qu'on
appelait la oficina de envigado le
bureau d'une vie gado avant d'aller
commettre leur assassinat
les tueurs à gage qu'on appelle les
sicav y'as vont se recueillir devant la
vierge qui leur est dédié à la mort
d'escobar au lieu de disparaître cette
mafia de medellin est devenue plus
puissante et plus actifs que jamais un
bébé in plus de 13000 personnes
travaillent aujourd'hui pour cette
organisation
ce spécialiste du crime organisé vit
sous la menace des groupes criminels
son bureau est littéralement blindés et
il ne se déplace jamais sans ses gardes
du corps
il s'appelle luis fernando qui fait
anormal on le consulte de partout car il
connaît les méandres du monde criminel
il explique comment fonctionne
aujourd'hui l'organisation qui a pris la
place du cartel de medellin
l on a ce truc tout d'abord il y a les
hommes de main les tueurs underworld est
alors au dessus il y aller cherche t
elle
puis le conseil de direction au siège
des représentants des différents clans
mafieux haut de la hiérarchie on
retrouve les patrons y mater les patrons
des patrons des patrons et staline pré
fall estime police ce sont des
entrepreneurs des politiciens des
autorités et ils sont très puissants ou
thema c'est une grande entreprise avec
un bras armé hall imparato militaire il
confirme la présence criminelles
transnationales dans son pays la
présidentielle cardinal watson arias
le cartel mexicain de sinaloa est ici
sont aussi présentes les mafias russes
chinoises et italiennes
wendy dio chatel l'a pas idiot à jude
quand elles font la paix il y a moins
d'homicides ça diminue la violence a
fait la réunionnaise violaine n'est pas
la criminalité et c'est ce qu'on vit à
medellin aujourd'hui yellow cayenne
nature
c'est dans cette réalité kateri frédéric
lavoie en mars 2014
il est en fuite depuis plus d'un an mais
on ignore où il s'est caché tout ce
temps-là s'affiche d'interpol décrit
comme le des criminels les plus
recherchés au canada quelques semaines
plus tard on découvre un corps aux
alentours de midi le cadavre démembré et
emballés dans des sacs en plastique a
été trouvé par le propriétaire d'un
terrain tout près de ce pont le corps
est identifié par les services de
médecine légale c'est celui de frédéric
lavoie nous avons demandé à notre expert
ce qu'on dit dans le monde criminel sur
ce meurtre
non on m'a dit qu'un canadien est venu
faire des affaires ici et qu'il n'a pas
rempli sa part du contrat
ça a mal tourné
mais dans la région un meurtre comme
celui de frédéric lavoie ne peut pas se
faire sans l'accord de la mafia locale
négoce certains sont venus de l'étranger
et de la mafia italienne pour faire des
affaires mais la mafia de medellin leur
a dit ici c'est nous qui avons le
contrôle et vous devez obtenir notre
permission
est il possible de commander un
assassinat en colombie depuis l'étranger
hier soir c'est très facile
on n'a qu'à faire en appel où on envoie
un message à nos partenaires d'affaires
et on leur demande d'embaucher quelqu'un
pour résoudre le problème et il s'en
occupe
[Musique]
nous avons poussé notre recherche dans
le monde interlope de medellin
un arc ou trafiquant local confirme ici
on dit le chien danse grâce à l'argent
tout peut s'obtenir avec de l'argent
dans ce pays
il y a tellement d'inégalités que si
l'on offre de l'argent les gens vont
faire ce qu'on leur demande
notre visite ne passe pas inaperçu
nos recherches dérange surtout les
fonctionnaires de l'état voici ce que
nous rapporte notre collaborateur
journalistes reconnus amis des lions une
de mes sources m'a dit il ya quelque
chose d'étrange dans cette affaire-là
qui sont pas tranquilles ne peut pas
nommer lui a demandé qui est en train de
réveiller tout ça qu'est-ce qu'il veut
savoir au juste
ça fait des années que je travaille
comme journaliste et que je fais des
enquêtes
c'est la première fois qu'on met autant
de bâtons dans les roues des
informations nous parviennent alors du
monde criminel
c'est délicat parce que des policiers
seraient impliqués dans la mort de la
voix la question demeure pourquoi
frédéric lavoie a été tué de façon aussi
violente et surtout que venait-il faire
en colombie en tout cas ce présumé
trafiquant n'était pas comme les autres
mais martin pourquoi la situation est
devenue aussi tendue dès notre arrivée à
médine
on s'était rendu compte que notre but
des sens déranger avant de partir je
l'avais contacté des gens des autorités
mais déjà des groupes criminels mais
quand nous sommes allés sur place on
s'était rendu compte nos collaborateurs
nos sources confidentielles et ne même
qui avait des gens qui venaient religion
espèce de mur de silence autour de cette
histoire
du côté des autorités les jantes sont
tous tombés malades pendant 9 semaines
et du côté du groupe criminel
on a compliqué à travers des messages en
rdc qui voudraient v10 et morlaàs qui
vous parlez de ce meurtre là c'était
tombé aux oubliettes
quoi ils sont intéressés dans c'est
certain que notre seule présence n'était
pas très aimé par déjà des l'état et des
gens des organisations pro mais n'ose
penser que j'ai été accueilli comme ça
ils sont que des côtés des autorités il
ya quelque chose à comprendre les gens
là mais jean ne sont pas contents des
voix cette association qui ont fait en
permanence surtout à l'étranger entre
les criminalités narcotrafic et cette
ville qui a beaucoup changé qui a moins
de meurtres aujourd'hui qui a motivé on
met de côté il est certes et vous savez
de découvrir dans l'histoire qui avait
déjà suffisamment puissante à mes jeans
pour essayer de nous semble pêcher des
clochers plus + société soir de savoir
c'est y est arrivé et a fait on s'était
rendu compte rapidement que les gens qui
étaient derrière ça il ne voulait pas
que cette histoire sort au grand jour
[Musique]
ici c'est le paradis sur terre pour les
narcotrafiquants
ici on est tout près de la frontière
avec l'équateur
pour nous la plante de coca c'est une
bénédiction parce que ça nous permet
d'envoyer les enfants à l'école et
d'avoir de quoi manger
les plantations de coca sont immenses et
les prix sont bas c'est ce qui est site
certains étrangers à venir
s'approvisionner sur place c'est par la
frontière de l'équateur que frédéric
lavoie seraient entrés en colombie après
selon nous sources
la voix est allé à cali la troisième
ville du pays pour y rencontrer une
femme les autorités colombiennes ne
savent pas qui élit mais elle l'aurait
accompagné ensuite à medellin
dès son arrivée frédéric lavoie aurait
essayé de refaire son réseau
d'importation de cocaïne
le général fossé mendoça directeur de la
lutte contre la drogue a enquêté sur ses
activités à medellin
il ne s'agissait pas de trafic important
c'était plutôt planifier des envois de
drogue et utiliser des personnes comme
courrier d'émules
c'est ce que nous dit lankais le
consortium dont auraient fait partie
frédéric lavoie était composée de
groupes du québec de l'ouest canadien de
la colombie du mexique et même de la
grèce une vraie multinationales de la
drogue mais qui n'aurait pas de
structures établies comme les hells
angels ou la mafia n'étant pas sur des
bases solides
ne connaissant pas tous les joueurs qui
travaillent au sein de son organisation
ont été restructurés au sein de
plusieurs gros à ce moment là sur risque
de créer une faille 17 file à la brèche
faire en sorte que la police peut
infiltrer peut travailler plus
facilement une organisation qui n'a pas
l'expérience
de contrer toute infiltration policière
à la suite de l'opération loquace en
2012 on à cusset six hommes d'avoir
importé de très grandes quantités de
cocaïne et d'en faire la distribution
parmi eux larry amero sur facebook
il ne cache pas son appartenance aux
hells angels il vient de colombie
britannique
en 2011 la voiture qu'il conduisait a
été criblée de balles
il était en compagnie d'un trafiquant de
drogue notoire mort sur le coup dans la
sphère locass qui date de 2012
un juge a récemment décidé d'abandonner
les accusations contre lui pour cause de
délais déraisonnables en raison de
l'arrêt jordan shane kenneth malone et
lui a plaidé coupable à des accusations
de trafic de cocaïne dans ses entrepôts
on a aussi retrouvé un grand nombre
d'armes à feu et des explosifs
philippe paul a participé à son
arrestation
c'est pas le genre de personne qui va
que la police pour obtenir beaucoup de
détails parce que c'est un criminel
endurci et puis sa façon de faire
au cours des dernières années a fait en
sorte qu'ils devenu une étoile montante
du crime organisé mais ça reste dans mon
livre à moi un trafiquant notoire
deux des présumées têtes dirigeantes
identifiés dans le cas ce sont encore
devant les tribunaux me caler leventis
errabie al-khalil timoléon une cicatrice
d'origine grecque était aussi en fuite
lors de la rafle policière de 2012
trois semaines plus tard on a retrouvé
son corps torturé et défigurée dans une
ville à l'est d'athènes
les journaux grecs mentionne la présence
dans leur pays des cartels mexicains
pour expliquer sa mort frédéric lavoie
qui n'était même pas connu des services
de police de sa région s'est retrouvé
dans ce groupe
comment at il fait est ce qu'il y avait
quelque chose qui vous laisser penser
qu'ils aient frédéric lavoie pouvait un
jour rentrer dans des affaires louches
vu de l'extérieur on s'imagine que c'est
des gens qui sont méchants pour être à
ce niveau là non il n'y avait pas sans
lui je l'ait jamais veut être vraiment
méchant avec quelqu'un je vois pas
comment il avait pu faire sa place là
dedans c'était quelqu'un de bien qui
était protecteur les femmes l'adoré
quelqu'un d'attentif et qui aimait
prendre soin des autres aussi dans un
message crypté écrit par la voix sous le
pseudonyme de king il réagit à la mort
accidentelle d'un complice si tu savais
comment j'étais proche de lui c'est un
gentil lui c'est pas comme les autres
hommes qui font du mal et à quel moment
tuft s'est rendu compte que sont les
styles des vies étaient commis rosella
de ce qu'il leur maman ça devrait être
quand je lis vos nouvelles comme quoi il
était recherché lorsque son corps est
identifiée en juin 2014
les témoignages de ses amis sur facebook
ne trompent pas fred tu vas me manquer
énormément mon frère je garderai
toujours de bons souvenirs ya des gens
plus marquée des événements qu'il ne
faut pas toujours chercher à comprendre
salvi le sujet souligne la voix le jt
mais surtout du côté où mais on essaie
des faits le parcours de sa vie
nous avons contacté sa famille et ses
amis mais peu d'entre eux ont accepté de
nous parler
la douleur est toujours vive et parfois
les sentiments sont ambivalents cette
personne a appris que frédéric avait
parfois caché de l'argent chez elle à
son issue est-ce qui vous a aussi ne
peut pas l'utiliser
y causer du tort des répercussions
autant sa famille ses amis
pas mal tout le monde et oui on se sent
trompé là dedans c'est sûr puis je me
demande moi si ou le changement s'est
fait à quel moment dans sa vie dans sa
tête
est ce qu'on est devenu moins importants
que ses propres vues dans les dernières
années je l' ai pas beaucoup vu mais les
fois que je l'aï vu c'était impossible
même pendant un dîner où une rencontre
d'avoir son attention plus que 30
secondes à la fois parce que bon il y
avait trois quatre cellulaire il a tout
le temps précieux il était juste
concentré sur ses conversations avec ses
trois quatre téléphones en texto fait
qu'envoyer locker tout ce qu'ils
vivaient est très préoccupant la voix
avait fait un voyage en colombie à
l'automne 2012
il veut alors développer un réseau
d'importation de drogue dans un
enregistrement réalisé à son issue il
révèle à son bras droit à voir former
une compagnie pour exporter de
l'équipement mécanique en colombie comme
frédéric lavoie a été tués en colombie
nous avons demandé au général oscar
naranjo décoré pour avoir combattu des
trafiquants toute sa carrière de se
pencher sur son histoire
c'est comme mourir pour le sua kay en
tant qu ancien policier aujourd'hui à la
retraite
je peux vous mentionnez trois ou quatre
choses qui ont attiré mon attention
d'abord l'âge de ce garçon
comment at il fait pour se bâtir si
rapidement une carrière criminelle et
devenir le sixième criminel le plus
recherché au canada
frédéric lavoie est recherché en vertu
d'un mandat international
un code rouge c'est à dire lorsqu'on
l'identifient on doit l'arrêter avant
même qu'ils entrent en colombie les
autorités sont prévenus ils voyagent
avec un passeport des bahamas sous une
fausse identité des travaux pas derrière
un faux passeport
il y a une structure criminels
sophistiqués qui dans ce cas à aider ce
canadien à venir en colombie alors on
peut conclure qu'on parle ici d'une
organisations criminelles
transnationales nationale et porte à nos
sources nous confirment que frédéric
lavoie avait des contacts en colombie si
j'ai finalement s'il est arrivé en
colombie
si parce qu auparavant il avait eu des
contacts au plus haut niveau
cole je crois qu'il avait réussi à
contacter un capot un chef du
narcotrafic reconnue et recherchée en
colombie et le contact de frédéric
lavoie dans ce pays aurait été le
narcotrafiquant daniel barreira une
vieille connaissance du général
cet individu est devenu en quelque sorte
mon obsession obsessions et les connu
dans le monde criminel sous le nom de
locaux barrère locaux barreira alias le
fou a été arrêté au venezuela avant que
la voix ne parte en cavale il a été
extradé aux états unis
comment frédéric lavoie aurait connu
celui qu'on considérait comme le nouveau
pablo escobar impossible de le savoir
lorsque la voix entame son dernier
voyage barreira est en prison son
organisation canada est décimée et la
police est à ses trousses son rêve de
richesse est sur le point de se briser
on présente souvent une seule facette
d'une heure contre al ahly on peut
devenir immensément riche grâce à la
drogue
faire de l'argent est devenu la
principale motivation des jeunes comme
celui ci on croit qu'ils peuvent devenir
très riche du jour au lendemain
peu importe il court le risque de mourir
après la pause le casse tête prend forme
et on s'approche de la vérité sur les
circonstances de la mort de frédéric
lavoie
[Musique]
medellin est aujourd'hui une destination
touristique recherché mais elle cache
toujours une autre réalité la plupart
des touristes viennent profiter de la
ville de son climat et de la gentillesse
des chances personnes quelques-uns
viennent pour la drogue les femmes et le
sexe drogue et sexe
la combinaison parfaite pour les
touristes qui cherchent on appelle la
rumba doura
ici c'est bon pour les affaires
la rumba les femmes l'exploitation
sexuelle les prix de file la
pornographie infantile ici c'est la
nouvelle
mais il ya aussi ces étrangers dont des
canadiens qui viennent ici pour
s'associer à des organisations
criminelles
parfois ils et laissent leur vie de 2016
quatre étrangers ont été assassinés les
étaient reliés au trafic de drogue et à
la pédophilie c'est un trafiquant est
prêt à tout pour atteindre son but était
d'évoquer minal il n'hésite pas à faire
pression sur les gens passionnants il
peut aller jusqu'au meurtre
selon les autorités colombiennes
frédéric lavoie est entré dans le pays
cinq semaines avant sa mort mais les
derniers jours il serait tombé dans les
mains des collecteurs de dettes de la
mafia à medellin et l'innovation
l'enquète nous montre que sa mort a
probablement un lien avec un
recouvrement d'une dette reliée au
narcotrafic dans ce milieu il y a
beaucoup de gens qui ne pardonne pas si
cet homme devait de l'argent et qu'il
n'a pas payé
il est arrivé ce qui devait arriver
enquête a appris que juste avant sa mort
en colombie
un envoyé de l'avoir amasser de l'argent
au canada pour lui et je pense qu'ils
allaient voir aussi plusieurs personnes
pour de l'argent est-ce qu'elle ferait
dans le besoin par ce qui est en cavale
où il le devait 1
je sais pas j'ai aucune idée pourquoi y
avait besoin d'argent
aucune idée d'où ce qui était non plus
pourquoi frédéric lavoie at il été
assassiné
première hypothèse le démantèlement de
son réseau a entraîné des pertes de
millions de dollars pour les
organisations criminelles qui en faisait
partie
deuxième hypothèse l'homme qui a
infiltré l'organisation et qui témoigne
maintenant au procès était le bras droit
de frédéric lavoie l'infiltrateur
raconté à la police que la voix lui
confiait bien naïvement
l'opération s'appelle loquace pour cette
raison l'inexpérience de la voix a peut
être aussi joué un rôle
le grand risque est celui de transiger
comme avait dit dans la cour des grands
dans une matière où ce que tu n'as pas
tellement l'habitude de faire et que
l'erreur est impardonnable
et comment expliquer le traitement cruel
infligé à frédéric lavoie et cela m'a
amené là où soual comment la mort pure
en colombie c'est la façon typique de la
mafia pour punir les trahisons et en
laissant le faux passeport ceux qui
l'ont assassiné voulais qu'il soit
identifié pour envoyer un message à ses
associés au canada mais implacable
à qui est stockée on marque c'est la
mafia qui est derrière ça des gens très
puissants que ça dérange et qui même des
années plus tard ne veulent pas qu'on en
parle ça alerte et tout le monde
l'enquète des autorités colombiennes n'a
rien donné jusqu'à maintenant on est
encore à l'étape de l' enquête
préliminaire
nous n'avons pu identifier ni l'auteur
du meurtre ni la personne qu'il aurait
commandité l'école curieusement chaque
fois qu'on parle de frédéric lavoie
nos sources nous parle d'un autre
canadien biais vivant celui là est et de
canadiennes et de canadiens dont on
parle est ici à medellin
depuis longtemps on connaît bien ses
activités il s'appelle brent krahn
williams arak singh un jeune homme de 32
ans originaire de toronto
il trempe dans le trafic de drogue mais
aussi dans d'autres activités
criminelles
nous avons clairement identifié deux
organisations criminelles
transnationales qui se disputent les
activités illégales en colombie surtout
un medellin
cet homme est à la tête de l'une d'elles
on le surnomme el gringo il est entré en
colombie en 2009 avec un faux passeport
lituanien toutes nos sources à medellin
sont convaincus que la voie ne pouvait
pas être ici sans qu'il le sache
il a son propre gang un groupe puissant
qui appartient à un autre plus grand
il a ses gardes du corps ce sont ces
hommes de main c'est sicario et les
aurait aussi pays pour assassiner
d'autres étrangers
araxxe il vient d'être condamné en
colombie à 15 ans de prison pour des
abus sexuels sur des mineurs
la police voulait l'interroger sur les
meurtres d'étrangers à medellin et
particulièrement sur celui de frédéric
lavoie
mais il a disparu dans la nature son
avocat a obtenu qu'il purge sa peine à
la maison pour des raisons de santé
l'autre est terminée et le may collectif
il s'est évadé s'est débarrassé de son
bracelet électronique et a fui en seo
cette piste n'a donc rien donné
avant que notre équipe qui est la
colombie on apprend que deux personnes
ont été arrêtées dans la sphère la voix
il effectue ses locaux de la police
effectivement nous avons arrêté deux
policiers qui auraient été engagés pour
faire disparaître le corps du canadien
le jour il a été tué et deux personnes
ont déjà comparu devant un juge
ils ont été formellement accusés
les deux policiers ne sont pas accusés
de meurtre ils disent ignorer qui a
assassiné la voix quant aux
commanditaires possible on pense aux
cartels mexicains
il fournissait la cocaïne transportée
par les roulottes jusqu'au canada
ils ont perdu beaucoup dans l'opération
la casse
l'argent mais surtout une porte d'entrée
pour acheminer la drogue
l'organisation criminelle est en droit
d'avoir des réponses des souvent on va
convoquer ces personnes là dans le pays
instigateur dans le pays d'où vient la
drogue que ce soit la colombie le
mexique ou autres pays producteurs
et puis si les réponses ne satisfait pas
aux besoins métiers des gros chances que
ces personnels sur canada voulait
renvoyer plus jamais
on ne sait pas qui est cerveau derrière
l'assassinât de frédéric lavoie
mais notre enquête a au moins permis de
savoir que ce meurtre ne peut
s'expliquer par une transaction qui a
mal tourné je n'ai jamais connu des
narcotrafiquants prospère qu'ils soient
encore en vie ou qu'ils soient riches
ils finissent pauvres ou en prison ou
mort assassiné par des gens de
l'organisation
toute cette histoire c'est une grande
tragédie
frédéric lavoie avait choisi la vie
qu'il menait
quand ils ont appris sa mort ce fut un
choc pour ses proches qui ont souffert
d'avoir perdu celui qu'ils aimaient
profondément ya peu est élevé dans un
milieu criminel c'est à dire de ce côté
là ma grande inquiétude c'est que cette
consommation des drogues alimente la
violence et cette violence peut mettre
fin à la vie des jeunes comme ce
canadien qui est venue mourir dans un
pays étranger loin de sa famille et de
son pays
assassiné par la mafia il y à des
développements récents dans notre
enquête on vous dit de quoi il s'agit
dans un instant
[Musique]
on est de retour enquête et il martin on
attend encore le procès des policiers
qui sont accusés d'avoir essayé de faire
disparaître le corps de la voix
effectivement et sa riche que des n'est
pas aboutir la réponse est simple les
témoins qui devaient pressent ont
simplement disparu comme par hasard il
ya aussi une personne que vous avez
interviewé dans votre partage qui a eu
des problèmes après votre passage
effectivement les responsables de la
sécurité des médecins c'est lui qui vous
venez de voir dénoncé la présence de la
criminalité canadienne sur place qui
dénonce les mafias se faire et et il y a
quelques jours par les autorités que
l'on bien qu'il accuse d'avoir des liens
avec la mafia des cinémas alors sur une
note plus joyeuse ont une belle semaine
enquête parce qu'on a remporté quatre
prix gémeaux notamment pour la meilleure
émission d'affaires publiques
on a reçu plusieurs félicitations de
votre part alors merci on est très
content oui ça me fait très plaisir vos
félicitations parce que évidemment cette
émission là on l'a fait pour vous elle
est déjà terminée mes revenus nous la
semaine prochaine pour une autre enquête
[Musique]